thank you Jerry so it's never too early
to start planning for Oktoberfest and
7-0 Brew is bringing the most authentic
celebration to The Orleans Festival
grounds and here to tell us about this
Extravaganza is John Venom from 7-0 Brew
it's good to see you buddy good to see
you Jason so what makes this the most
authentic Oktoberfest celebration you
know I grew up in Germany my dad was in
the military I was an Army brat we grew
up in a leather a little town in the
southern part of Germany uh you know in
the 70s and 80s there were more than 300
000 U.S servicemen over in Germany and
so we kind of got that culture ingrained
in us and it just is such a fun
environment that we're I'm bringing that
here
um you know a couple of years ago we
wanted to do it we kind of got sidelined
with uh kovid yeah
behind us now we imported 500 of these
tables yeah just these are these
disabled loans this is from this is a
German this is an authentic Oktoberfest
table okay uh that's imported so we've
got these and we've got our full one
liter Steins yeah so we're gonna have
beer out there right incredible beer
we've got over 12 different kinds of
brands that are there not just Brands
but you know each of those have
different kinds of beers associated with
them but Lennon kugel we're going to
have a Lennon kugel Stein holding oh I'm
good at that we hold it out there let's
see if we can do this the rest of the
segment here it's easy there's no liquid
in it it's very easy when there's no
liquid and you're not allowed to drink
it while you're doing this gotta hold it
out the whole entire time talk to me
about the food you're gonna have here
yeah there's incredible food that's
authentic German so you know just these
are some of the bakery items that we're
going to have the authentic German
politkin
What's this called that's a bloat him so
they serve this with the brat forest and
the horse and all those other things
that you know those great sausages that
we're gonna have out there
um we're gonna have lot Vost which is
red red sausage we're gonna have Curry
Forest we're gonna have
um just a dozen a dozen or more
different I love that you're saying it
properly too well you know German was my
first language so we lived off base uh
in a little village of about 600 people
and so I went to German kindergarten for
the first two years that I could go to
school so you're bringing the real deal
to The Orleans I'm trying to bring as
real as we can you know there's lots of
Oktoberfest in the country but we have
not had one in Las Vegas like this and
within five years I want to make ours
the best in the country and I know you
have some entertainment lined up what
kind of entertainment do you have more
than 50 acts coming in from all over the
country most of them are authentic
Germans uh from from Germany uh so we've
got a band that's coming in called the
ladyhosen all females uh Hammerstein's
coming in the barbar skis so we've got a
ton of German bands some locals as well
that are going to help pepper in we've
got a German uh Village that we've kind
of you know are created by crickets and
goods there's ticket packages are
available by one day three and by one
day four day passes we're here Thursday
through Sunday so you can come all four
days because there's going to be lots of
different things on each day we've got a
big large truck show and car show
benefiting Speedway Children's Charities
I love it so lots of great things to
come for the entire family we've got a
70-foot ferris wheel overlooking the
strip so you've got everything come for
the booze come for the come for the beer
or come for the food I gotta wrap it up
here two quick things this is not a real
Lederhosen you'll have the real deal
come up to overfest right yes we'll have
real later hoses and durdles the ladies
are dermals yeah before we wrap what
should I try I want to try something I
tried pretzel a pretzel out of all these
things tell me pretzel and in German and
well because they're not like American
pretzels and in Germany they're called
and uh so you know you can you can eat
the the soft part you can eat the
crunchy part uh now authentic Germans
they don't eat it with mustard like
Americans do we dip it in beer
I gotta wrap it up thank you so much
we're looking forward to Oktoberfest
seven of Brews Oktoberfest is coming to
The Orleans Festival grounds this is
happening end of September the 29th
through October 2nd tickets are on sale
now at sevenobrew.com Jillian save me a
pretzel